new free trade agreement means british
cars scotch whiskey
biscuits and ceramics will be cheaper to
sell into australia
british farmers who had concerns about
being undercut will be protected by a
cap
on tariff-free imports lasting up to 15
years
also under the agreement brits under the
age of 35 will be able to travel and
work in australia more freely uh well
we'll speak to laura lowe in a moment
uh she's hoping that this new deal will
mean that she can move back to australia
with her new british partner
but first let's speak to the president
of the national farmers union minette
batters to find out her concerns
there were a lot of concerns from
british farmers weren't there as this
trade deal was going through
they obviously don't want the uk market
flooded with a competitor's product like
australian beef or lamb what are your
concerns though about what has finally
been agreed
i must say firstly that we welcome
trading relationships
with our commonwealth cousins you know
the australia trade deal
has obviously been at the forefront uh
of these other trade discussions but it
has always been
about constructive liberalization and
i've worked with three different
secretaries of state and defer now
we've all prioritized having sensitive
sectors with australia
it's beef lamb and sugar so we see a
15-year
transition but we have very very little
detail as to
what that will actually look like and
australia is a very well developed
um trade uh exporter if you like of
agricultural products they have 22
agricultural councillors across the
world we have two
so we really do have and i keep on
saying this to the secretary of state
and indeed the prime minister we must
start to put effectively boots on the
ground across the world
so that we are competitive with
australia but also new zealand
canada america and mexico um to date
we are no further on uh with what those
councils will look like or indeed the
match funding
uh for the farmer levy that australia
has we
are not um uh receiving that either yet
so there's a lot that needs to happen to
get competitive
with australia away from the actual nuts
and bolts of this particular deal with
australia though
um are you confident or are you hopeful
that the ramifications
for the broader asia pacific free trade
agreement
that may come from it could be really
helpful for british farmers
only if we've got what i just said in
place you know these are technical roles
they need people
over in these countries to make sure
those markets are opened up at the
moment we have one person out of
uh out in china you know australia has
as i said 22 people so that's what's
needed
you know trans-pacific is not just a
given you have to have people on the
ground to do
that work and that is what we don't have
um it's also a precedent deal
so with new zealand in third round of
negotiations australia will create a
precedent
for how we trade now you know my focus
has always been on
on driving our high standard of animal
welfare and environmental protection
across the world and particularly with
climate change
this is incredibly important to show
leadership and
i just feel this has been rushed i don't
think anybody including the australians
quite understand the rush their media
is continually saying to me what what is
the rush about so
we wait to see the detail but ultimately
it leads to long-term liberalization
and at the moment i don't have the
detail for what the 15-year roadmap
actually looks like in terms of food
standards i mean that is obviously a
concern for consumers
and for farmers as well as trust in the
last short while has said that
for example hormone injected beef will
not be allowed
into britain we know that there are some
concerns about hormone injections
pesticides
and feed additives in australia i mean
are you uh
confident that actually it can work the
opposite way that our high food
standards
could lead to potentially changes in
australia which we know which could
affect animal welfare positively
well only if we put it in into the trade
deal which you know today
we we haven't done and i would say it is
probably a bit late to be talking about
it
and now you know australia does have
access to our market
already so you know they can produce to
our food safety standards but we are
raising the standards here there is a
bill going through parliament at the
moment
kept animals bill that is looking to
raise standards we've banned live animal
exports across a 20-mile stretch
of the channel obviously in australia
you can travel animals for
thousands of miles so it's really about
a fair
and level playing field and making sure
that our farmers
aren't undermined that we export more of
what we're good at
and we make sure that british food is
really accessible to
everybody i think on the back of covet
people want to buy local they want to
buy seasonal
and you know we've got to be focusing on
on that effectively that by british
messages as well
as constructive trade deals okay minette
batters
president of the national farmers union
thanks very much uh let's now bring in
laura lowe uh now laura i can tell you
uh is desperate to move
out to australia hi laura thanks for
joining us
so you so you are australian tell us
tell us a little bit about your
circumstances
yes i am australian i moved to the uk
when i was 10 years old with my parents
um i do have a dual nationality so i can
stay in the uk but
since being here so long um i think it's
time to go back home
and last year um i was supposed to go
home
i had a plane ticket booked my english
partner had a visa book
and three days before we were supposed
to fly australia shut the borders
unfortunately i could have still gone
but i couldn't leave my boyfriend behind
so
i decided to stay and try and ride it
out and
hope for the best that the bodies will
open but again
it's just a waiting game at the moment
and obviously his visa has expired so i
believe this new visa scheme will very
much help
because it's quite an expensive
procedure isn't it trying to get all
these kind of visas so
from your understanding of this new
trade deal is it going to mean that
when covert restrictions are relaxed you
and your partner could move back to
australia for a while or even
permanently
oh yes definitely it's mainly on the
cards to be permanent because
he wants a new life and obviously he
wants to see some sun and
i've been with him for four years so
having a visa that can expand to three
years would be very
a great opportunity and also a great
opportunity
opportunity to other british people
because
with cobit right now i think everyone
needs a break
and also to basically live life because
i'm sure everyone has witnessed now that
life is so short and
now it's time to just get on a plane to
australia and
yeah well i'm sure there's lots of
people who would
who would love to do that with you laura
what does your partner think about about
it all i mean is he
is he keen just to start a new life out
there
please yes he was very much devastated
when we couldn't get on that plane
we quit our jobs we moved house
i even gave up my pets which was quite
horrible to do and yeah it's it was very
devastating it played a part in our
relationship and
yeah we're staying strong and i believe
it's going to work really well